would you consider yourself to be a
because I think there's a difference
between being a religious person and a
spiritual person yeah what what uh side
of the pendulum do you swing on if any
um I mean there's a you know there's a
there's a balance between the two
because you know I obviously you know
grew up in the Christian church
I am the black Liv Pastor you know what
I'm saying
um but
um you know I do you know ask questions
I do you know
study theology I'm I'm into it all and
you know all of the messages are you
know relative
in essence you know what I'm saying um
so you know to answer your question I'm
just kind of in between somewhere in
between the two somewhere in between the
two but I mean you know I I you know I I
I tell you I'm a Christian right who has
questions
what do you mean that's your you're a
Christian who also asked questions yeah
a Christian who asked questions yeah
that's fair there you go yeah I feel
like uh I was kind of like uh more uh
atheist for a long time but once I
started doing a lot of like Heavies like
psychedelics it's just I'm just more
like I don't know now you know yes and
that's and that's but the wisest man
knows he knows
nothing you know what I'm saying and so
it's like
and it's crazy how atheist is such a
that word is just so strong right
atheist that's so such a strong it's a
harsh word if you just say it I should
just say yeah that's crazy people look
at you like you say I'm a Satanist yeah
you might as well tell certain people
here yeah exactly right but yeah but you
know like I said man
do without oil you know yeah I
definitely believe in Alien so I mean
you know I don't even want to go here my
thing is yeah
I ain't got enough time no but if aliens
are real right so if they're real if if
if they oh oh so we're doing that I
think they are okay so yeah do you think
they are I'm not saying if are you
saying that they are I've seen some [ __ ]
oh man but if if we find out yeah aliens
are a [ __ ] thing right doesn't that
poke holds through a lot of the
religions of the world
or no no no because if because when you
do the research they're they're there
they're there you know start the serpent
the serpent that was the
uh you know that was the you know like
they were there the whole time we just
didn't look at it through the proper
lens yeah it's just because they're very
they're very poetic you know just and
that's just the you know the whole you
know the Christian Bible they're all
there there's you know
if you if you choose to if you choose to
look at it you choose to dig in yeah
they're they're always there there's
always beings
you know what I'm saying like
unexplainable beings that you know this
this and that you know Nephilim you know
just all kind of have you ever uh
witnessed the UFO
yeah
I'll give you this
UFO means what unidentified flying
object I mean by definition if you if
you it could be a Southwest if you if if
you if you saw it why isn't it why is it
unidentified
yeah I'm just on that you know you know
how long you know what I'm on the kids
I'm trying to play like yeah
I've seen I've had a couple of UFO
sightings I mean
shit's crazy listen
Strawberry Fields
shout out to The Beatles nothing is real
that is a great song to each room's on
and listen to oh man have you ever have
you ever ate shrooms while listening to
that song Oh man it's a [ __ ] great
song man I've been uh
I've broke through to the other side but
many many times